hi welcome back i'm so excited to
welcome our next guest to cookbook club
however he is a very good friend of the
show he's 18 year old culinary
personality and social media superstar
whose posts are both delicious and
beyond entertaining welcome our pal etan
vernon
hi drew i'm super excited to be here are
you a cookbook fan yes so it's actually
something we have in common which
probably makes sense why we like each
other so much is i love cookbooks also
uh ever since i was a little kid all my
presents were cookbooks i have a similar
desk to this and on the top shelf is
just cookbooks so
i'm i love cookbooks
i probably like 50 to 100. i mean it's
interesting because you know i'm not
like a great cook let's that's just i'm
honest about it i'm messy and i'm gonna
change that all over the place it's true
i'm going to learn from people like you
and i obsessively watch
tv shows i especially
obsessively watch videos like yours and
i obsessively read cookbooks and that's
like the only way i know how to do
anything in the kitchen i'll be at messi
i just have fun with that now should we
do a little cookbook club before we
start cooking let's do it okay so did
you bring a cookbook for me of course
i brought you this one my favorite
cookbooks it is sababa by my good friend
adina sussman and this is all about her
living in tel aviv and all the israeli
food and middle eastern food that she
cooks and eats and what i really love
about is she does such a good job
through the writing and the photos of
like transporting you into tel aviv and
experiencing it with her so the and also
obviously the food's just delicious
um etan have you ever been to tel aviv
i have and actually when i came back i
was craving all that food i always joke
that i get pregnancy cravings even
though that's physically impossible um
and
i was craving all that food and then
deena came out with the book pretty
shortly after that and i was like this
is exactly what i needed to recreate all
the food i've been craving oh my gosh
eitan take me to tel aviv please
when we get done when it's safe i mean
look at how beautiful this is eitan this
is going to make such a gorgeous
addition to my collection thank you so
much i didn't have this one and i really
love and know about her and now i can
really love and know about her okay i'm
going to show you the cookbook i brought
you today are you ready
it's called a very serious cookbook that
sounds like the antithesis of me i am
like the least serious chef i just 100
fun in the kitchen for me well wait
until you look inside because the title
is very deceptive it's super cool and
they teach you all these really
interesting like there definitely are
some fancier recipes but when they talk
about like a blue crab celery with
asparagus they talk about like what you
should look for in a crab or
it's very geeky and foodie and
very um
it has so much knowledgeable
information about
when you're picking things or
how to break down a sauce and you're so
smart in the kitchen that i kind of
wanted to get you a smarty book
i love that i i always love learning i
always say that even though right now
i'm not currently enrolled in any school
i feel like life is all about learning
your whole life i'm looking i'm very
excited to be through it like it's like
the breakdown of the palette i just
think it's super cool so i'm excited to
share that with you i will be reading it
for sure all right all this cookbook
talk's getting me hungry oh my gosh i am
so excited do you know what one of my
favorite dishes in the world is eitan
i believe it's paniala vodka from rice
there you go that's what it's cooking
today i'm so excited and i've watched
you on tick-tock do your thing where you
do the
i mean it's like i don't am i doing that
um let me do it first okay and then
you'll back up and maybe you'll give it
a try uh i'll do it first should we get
started cooking all you should know is
that daniel our king of props is
standing by with a fire extinguisher
all right let's do it so in our first
pot over here we are going to heat up
our olive oil
right in there
alrighty now
after that i'm going to add in 10 cloves
of sliced garlic now typically i would
say this is a good like date night
dinner although
your breath will probably smell
you know what though like honestly fresh
garlic on breath is
that that isn't like what kind of
i think the whole like garlic breath is
a little bit of a myth that's kind of
sexy and like you know
i i i don't i don't mind it
same all right now instead do you like
spicy food drew yes i do awesome so
we're now going to add in our red chili
flakes which is going to add a beautiful
layer of spice to the dish if you at
home don't like spicy food as much you
could add in less you could add more
whatever whatever you want
[Music]
i like it the spicy
yes and now do you smell that it like
fills your kitchen with the most
incredible smell i mean eitan it's so
beautiful it's already
smelling like i am a professional chef
myself so you are really
empowering me right now
there you go now you want now cook this
down for about three four five minutes
but with a little tv magic mine is
magically already done and now it is
time for the fun part all right are you
ready for this i am do i do it in this
sauce or do i keep this burning what do
i do
keep this going now let me do it first
through i'm going to add in my vodka now
what we're doing is penny al vodka the
reason it has such that incredible
flavor is you know what a bottle of
alcohol it'll say like 40 alcohol
uh i never paid attention i just drank
it but yeah go on
okay well it says 40 or whatever percent
so we're using the other percent that
isn't alcohol so we're going to be
cooking out all the alcohol and we're
left with the other 60 or that's usually
around what it's about percent which is
jam-packed with flavor if you don't want
to flambe it after you've seen me doing
this or if you're at home you can just
add it into tomato sauce and boil the
vodka the alcohol out but i think this
is a little bit more fun so i'm going to
add it in and carefully light it on fire
nope come on
light it on fire there we go all right
it is now coming down another quick way
to quickly in the kitchen fun fact never
put water on a fire like that just cover
it and now the fire is out
do you want to try drew yes i do
i do
i mean i literally have daniel right
there with the fire extinguisher okay
stand back while you do it okay am i am
i doing it on my oil and garlic
yes on your oil and garlic add it in and
then you're gonna quickly light and jump
back
oh my god
oh my god oh my gosh okay
oh gosh darn it
[Music]
i did it
you're flogged there we go come on i'm
your first time
braver than this
all right
my fire was puny compared to yours and
my garlic is burning
well luckily we're a little tv magic
exactly done but before that we're gonna
add in our can of crushed or the whole
peeled tomatoes that you then crushed
with your hands add that into there
stir it up
how's yours looking i burnt my garlic
eton how do you not burn garlic
uh your flame probably was a little too
high so next time next time you lower
flame i feel like my problem is is that
i always put the pan on when we start
and then it's not hot enough so this
time i over compensated so as i like to
say i need to find the pretty little
middle
yes
now with little tv magic we don't have
to worry about your garlic being burnt
because we already have our blended up
sauce right over here look at that
luscious sauce how good does that look
so after this you would uh would you
blend it would you immersion blend it
how would you
like to use a regular blender i think
that's the best way to do it just in a
regular blender you can obviously use
emerging blender but i think a real
blender you want to get it really really
blended up okay so you want like a
really smooth puree not a chunky smooth
but a smooth smooth
if you like it chunky you can do that i
like it smooth but i would say with
cooking like you don't have to be exact
just make it how you like now into this
sauce we're now going to add in our
heavy cream we're adding a cup of heavy
cream and we're going to add in a cup of
grated parmesan now there's quite a lot
of
cream and parmesan but this is a very
luscious fat filled sauce
i'm gonna
exercise and do whatever it takes to
compensate
for this sauce all right now we're gonna
stir that together and melt it up okay
i'm getting so excited i feel like when
you cook like a big thing of pasta it's
like you have your whole family around
it's just kind of like a very like
family type of meal you know you gotta
have people with you enjoying the food
while you're doing it i'm lucky i have a
lot of people around here not to drop
names it sucks when one of your best
friends has a name that you recognize
we've been friends since i was 14 and
she was 16. cameron diaz and i we say a
parmigiano and then we
say like 50 times in a row and then we
start saying it different weird ways
parmigiano parmigiano
and that's our thing so i literally
can't look at parmigiano
without thinking of her because it's one
of our longest running inside jokes
i love that pardon me awesome
and then we get like really sad we're
like
parmesan
now we're gonna add in our cooked pasta
each one obviously cook your pasta to
whatever it says on the box to round the
al dente and i'm now do you know what
dente means i certainly do and i don't
like it anything but
okay good okay i was testing your your
kitchen knowledge because you clean you
don't know how to cook but i mean it
looks like you do um i you know it's
just because i get lucky enough to
surround myself
you know we you and i hung out with like
gordon ramsay the other day and you're
such an amazing chef and i just keep it
real about what a messy
kind of
non-aficionado i am in the kitchen but
i'm so passionate about it and when i
travel i really try to unless i'm
working i try to base my travel and food
and i study food and i live food and i
understand food and i eat a lot of food
and i am a lover and an appreciator and
an adorer of food so i agree i kind of
don't understand any pasta that isn't al
dente oh all this food talk's getting me
hungry drew oh my god me too let's be
truthful i'm dying to try this
yes so let's now spoon it into our bowl
although honestly sometimes if i just
make this for myself you can eat right
out of the pan i will not judge you i
have definitely done that at least a few
times my favorite thing is to
uh put on my new favorite show that i'm
binging
um especially if i just binge santa
clarita diet i actually like i did
almost i'm like a workaholic i always
work but i literally stopped work like
three days like okay i'm sorry everyone
i need to just finish watching the show
uh so yeah it was i'm a big fan that was
that was a lot of fun oh my gosh heyton
i'm so excited that you watched it we
had so
much fun making that show it was one of
those shows where we knew we were making
something like bizarre and irreverent
and netflix just let us go all the way
with it and it was just
it was three really wonderful years of
my life and i love sheila hammond
because
gosh we all need more sheila hammond in
our life
yes and now the last step is just take i
like to be a little bougie while i'm in
the kitchen so i just like to take a
little bit of some fresh oregano on top
for a little bit of green you have to
have a garnish that's what sells the
fanciness
yeah so i mean we eat with our eyes
first so it's very important that it
looks good and tastes good and i think
that one of my favorite things in food
is making sure as you said that color
balance is there so this just makes it
beautiful and special and oh my gosh i'm
so excited i can't believe i'm finally
gonna get to eat eton's penny alla vodka
here we go
no pressure or anything i've only
watched you cook this like 15 times
oh my god
booty shot
oh my gosh
eitan what do you think what are you
thinking i love it so much it's so
incredible and
you know what's good when the person
doesn't want to talk they just want to
eat it hey john you literally took the
words right out of my mouth i was like i
don't know how to say this but i don't
want to talk right now i just want to
shovel
i'm so excited to eat one of your really
signature dishes
thank you so much and now because i have
to tell you i've never made panela vodka
so thank you for teaching me to make a
dish i love
but it's your version of it that i love
thank you eton so much
[Music]
you